[Musica]
un tempo ci fermavamo un'opinione
soprattutto così adesso così complice la
pandemia
se prima i social ero nel posto in cui
andavamo per dimenticarci del mondo
adesso sono del posto in cui andiamo per
scoprirlo
il mondo ed è come se fosse in atto uno
switch d'influenza dai partiti non più
strutturati identitari come un tempo a
delle singole persone che hanno una loro
community
i loro canali di distribuzione e una
loro identità fortissima i clienti
influenza e creato sparlano sempre più
d'attualità perché lo sentono perché
glielo chiede il colore perché sanno che
stare su una piazza e parlare solo di se
stessi alla lunga annoia in america
celebrity sportive come lebron james
sono diventate dei punti di riferimento
politici per un'intera generazione
c'è stato un momento in cui gli atleti
avevano paura di parlare di attualità
noi no noi non rimarremo gt a
palleggiare ha detto su twitter sono
nate le colla bounce pagine collettive
da ragazzi che hanno lo stesso
orientamento politico e che fanno
divulgazione attivismo c'è la pagina dei
repubblicani quella di libera e così via
e anche in italia capita sempre di più
che l'agenda politica venga dettata dai
creatori l'ha fatto per ora ramazzotti
con il cup colin chiara ferragni con i
vaccini fede con i diritti civili è così
via attenzione non danno mai una visione
totalizzante del mondo come quella che
davano i vecchi partiti sinistra destra
si esprimono su temi precisi chirurgici
ambientalismo antirazzismo gender gap
diritti civili
e così via ora è un bene secondo me si è
sempre un bene che qualcuno parli di
quello che vuole su determinati temi poi
il dibattito si democratizza e la platea
si allarga ma una condizione che venga
preservata e salvaguardata la
complessità dei temi stessi
per fare questo è necessario che anche
il nostro senso critico sia fini sempre
di più personalmente per valutare
l'attendibilità l'onestà e il valore
intellettuale di un creatore che mi
parla di attualità
io mi faccio cinque domande primo
e aperto al confronto ovvero legge
approfondisce e saprebbe espormi le tesi
di chi non la pensa come lui o si sta
limitando a delegittimarmi nel primo
caso ne arricchisce nel secondo non fa
bene alla democrazia e molto
probabilmente non farà bene neanche a me
perché qualcosa che non si contaminano
rimane cura diventa sterile diventa
fascismo digitale definire omofobo
qualcuno che critica una legge non
significa alimentare dibattito significa
a soffocarlo intervistare in una live
chi la pensa come te non significa
confrontarsi significa spalleggiarsi e
sentirsi offeso non significa
automaticamente avere ragione in questo
credo che possa aiutarci molto la parola
partito che con tutti i suoi difetti
però ci ricorda sempre che si tratta di
una parte della società
una parte della società che la pensa in
un certo modo e che dovrà sempre
confrontarsi con un'altra parte che la
pensa diversamente e non sarà mai tutto
il totale quello succede solo nelle
dittature nei totalitarismi come dice la
parola stessa
il mondo è complesso e si fa con i
compromessi ha detto barack obama tirare
pietre sui social non significa fare
attivismo secondo sta dicendo qualcosa
con cui qualcuno può esplicitamente
essere in disaccordo
se sta dicendo soltanto che contro il
razzismo per l'ambientalismo per
l'empowerment vista solo dando una
versione più patinata del classico
voglio la pace nel mondo
chiunque vuole la pace del mondo anche
chi fa la guerra dice che la fa per la
pace nel mondo
faccio un esempio se i per l'ambiente
per le borracce ok ma poi ragioniamo
approfondiamo vuoi tassare le ammissioni
dell'azienda petrolifera
ti stai scagliando contro quel metodo di
produzione di quella tale azienda
d'abbigliamento
perché se ti stai mantenendo così
generico in modo da non trovare nessuno
in disaccordo
forse stai solo facendo un elegante
attività di pubbliche relazioni digitali
che va benissimo però è un'altra cosa
terzo ha studiato qui è come ci diceva
la maestra delle elementari cioè a
passatore col sedere sulla sedia a
leggere approfondire i temi di cui parla
tanto perché rispetto a un messaggio
superficiale con cui sono d'accordo
preferisco un messaggio profondo con cui
sono in disaccordo quarto sta usando se
stesso per parlare degli altri forse
usando gli altri per parlare di se
stesso
l'attivismo in atto teso verso gli altri
non verso di noi e c'è una bella
differenza tra chiusa la sua immagine
per fare delle battaglie e ci usa delle
battaglie per affinare la sua immagine
magari per posizionarsi
comunicativamente rendersi più
appetibile per le collaborazioni con gli
altri brand personalmente inorridisco
quando sento dire che di neri devono
parlare solo i neri e di donne sono le
donne perché la negazione stessa del
concetto di attivismo e politica che per
definizione sono e si significano
occuparsi degli altri che non solo noi e
che sono diversissimi da noi
immaginate se marco pannella attivista
nel per il diritto all'aborto al
divorzio è un carcere più ma uno avesse
detto non ho di questi temi se ne deve
occupare soltanto chi ha abortito che ha
divorziato e c'è stato in carcere
quinta e ultima sta facendo qualcosa
sembra banale
un attivismo come dice la parola stessa
significa attività significa qualcosa di
concreto di misurabile i simboli sono
importanti sono importantissimi ma da
soli
servono solamente a fare ngage mente ea
fare le frasi delle cover it e cellulari
virtus signaling si chiama fare posto
buonisti solo per segnalare che sei
bello bravo e buono e quindi la domanda
è sta partecipando a un movimento o sta
solo sfruttando un momento per farsi
promozione personale
se la maggior parte delle risposte a
queste domande sono positive allora
penso di aver trovato una un'altra
una fonte per formare la mia opinione se
sono negative magari continuerò a
seguire quel che eto'o ma lo farò con un
occhio ancora più critico per il resto
mi fido sempre del mio istinto e diffido
sempre dei bacchettoni social perché gli
uomini e le donne che cambiano il mondo
e quelli che storicamente l'hanno
cambiato non sono mai state quelle
perfette sono inventò avide narcise
disordinate dispettosi di uscire non
sono né cattivi né patinate sono vive e
in tutte noi ritroviamo quello che indro
montanelli ritrovo il marco pannella 1
con cui non era mai d'accordo
marco pannella fa un sacco di matta le
miss di casini ma lui ritrovo quello che
io sono stato a tentarlo